congressional Republicans are trying to
push through some big changes to the
financial regulations passed after the
economic crisis of 2008 tonight chief
congressional correspondent Mike Emanuel
tells us lawmakers in the Senate and the
house are still wrangling over who's
version is best
both House and Senate Republicans are
eager to rollback dodd-frank banking
regulations but some key House members
want to go further than the Senate bill
it's clear House Speaker Paul Ryan sees
it as an important part of the agenda
even with the Senate as slow as they are
we're gonna be repealing and replacing
dodd-frank so we're actually getting a
great deal done for the country last
week White House budget director Mick
Mulvaney told House members he'd like
the Senate bill to include more of their
ideas to the extent that you all have
done really good work to find ways it's
on a bipartisan basis to improve
dodd-frank god bless you and let's see
if we can't add that to the Senate bill
if not Senate bills a great fallback but
if it can get better
why wouldn't we accept that as a really
good outcome 16 Democrats voted for the
legislation in the Senate including some
facing what are expected to be tough
reelection campaigns and who are
co-sponsors of this bill Donnelly in
Indiana hike camp North Dakota Manchin
West Virginia McCaskill Missouri and
tester Montana there's a political
calculation here because those Democrats
are under intense pressure from Ohio
senator sherrod Brown and Massachusetts
senator Elizabeth Warren and their
allies the American people aren't going
to stand by while the big banks and
other giant corporations run this
economy and this Congress for their own
benefit Republicans are focused on
delivering a win for president Trump and
on a promise to their supporters so that
can mean settling for what the Senate
has already passed but it could also be
a win for some red state Democrats
particularly in Trump State these
Democrats they're risking ire from an
energized far-left base to do the right
thing in an election year to help people
good for them they deserve credit for
that if they do that and Republicans
absolutely should not let politics stand
in the way here
this is broken down to a bit of a
squabble some on the Senate side said
they only wanted to vote on this issue
once House leadership says it wants the
voices of its members to be heard and
they're not asking for controversial
items both sides insists they want to
put a bill on the President's desk right
we'll follow it Mike Emanuel live on the
hill Mike thanks